Ma tu pensi che sia scema non fare finta
di niente sai e quella ti fa guidato il
tuo numero non mi interessa se era
quella delle ricariche sai Potevi
fartela fare da un ragazzo Invece no ti
ho voluto fartela fare proprio da lei
porco ma tu lo sai che c'è una sfida di
ragazzi fuori dalla porta che vorrebbero
uscire con me Ah la cacca di papà
capricciosa Ma sei deficiente cosa Ah
era una battuta Bella battuta di merda
Sì allora lasciami fare coraggio Voglio
proprio vedere dove vai in vacanza
quest'estate senza lo yacht la villa dei
miei che stai facendo Scusa c'è uno
scherzo Mi sta lasciando sul serio Cioè
tu stai lasciando me e cosa avrei fatto
scusa per farmi lasciare ma tu sei pazzo
La mia era una battuta Mica le puoi fare
solo tu le battute dai Secondo me
abbiamo un po' Esagerato Lo sai che io
sono un po' pazzerella ti piace anche
per questo no la tua Dottor Jekyll e
Mister Hyde pace pesciolino